Встановити один модуль доволі швидко. Але їх багато тисяч.
Ці монтажники будують поблизу Берліна найбільший сонячний парк у Німеччині.
Керівник проєкту Торстен Йорс хоче завершити будівельні роботи за один рік.
Насправді протягом останніх років фотогальваніки знову побільшало.
Значно більше ці технології використовували з 2010 по 2012 роки.
Але приблизно протягом останніх трьох років попит на фотогальваніку знову дуже сильно зростає як у сегменті дахових систем, так і на відкритих просторах.
Німеччина хоче відмовитися від вугільної енергетики до 2038 року, атомної енергетики теж більше не буде.
Тож, як сонячна енергія може допомогти задовольнити попит на електроенергію?
І як це змінить ландшафт країни?
Пів мільйона модулів на металевих рамах.
100 тисяч опорних стовпців.
250 кілометрів кабелю.
150 майстрів. Замовник цього - одна з найбільших енергетичних груп Німеччини.
Тут, у Бранденбурзі, ми дійсно маємо можливість реалізовувати проєкти у такому масштабі,
але я б не сказав, що всі наступні проєкти мають бути ще більшими.
Натомість важливо, щоб проєкт був економічно виправданим.
Площа - 225 футбольних полів завбільшки.
Сонячні парки у Європі в основному невеликі, оскільки конкурують із сільськогосподарськими угіддями.
Інші ж сонячні парки, приміром, в індійських пустельних районах, можуть забезпечувати понад пів мільйона домогосподарств.
Але лише сонячні парки не дадуть достатньої кількості електроенергії.
У Німеччині - 19 мільйонів житлових будинків із достатньо великою площею дахів. Ідеальне місце для сонячних систем.
Ціла галузь вже давно спеціалізується на цьому, бо сонячні дахи окупаються.
Нині вже можна придбати систему дуже дешево і при цьому економно експлуатувати її,
оскільки в принципі вагомих витрат на обслуговування системи немає.
А витрати на систему сьогодні настільки дешеві, що їх можна відбити дуже швидко.
Марк Шварц - один із домовласників із сонячним дахом.
Нині для багатьох цілком нормально, що власна система виробляє більше електроенергії, ніж сама використовує.
Це окупається фінансово ще й тому, що витрати, пов’язані з постачанням енергії для опалення будівель
або на опалення води для побутових потреб, є цілком прийнятними.
Оскільки мешканці самі виробляють електроенергію, яку споживають,
за неї більше не потрібно платити, тож, така система окупиться вже за кілька років.
Тим не менше Марк Шварц споживає трохи більше електроенергії, ніж виробляє.
Адже родина Шварців їздить на двох електромобілях.
Але хіба не можна на усіх дахах Німеччини виробити достатньо енергії, щоб забезпечити цілу країну струмом?
Компанія Juwi будує сонячні парки у Європі. Як оцінює це рада директорів компанії?
Сонячна енергія з дахів важлива, але цього буде недостатньо, щоб забезпечити нас усіх енергією.
Потрібно розрізняти, бо серед поверхонь дахів є такі, що технічно придатні, а слід враховувати ще й те, чи окупиться це економічно.
Фахівці прогнозують збільшення обсягів сонячної енергії у Німеччині.
Коли у 2038 році закриють останню у ФРН ТЕС, що працює на вугіллі,
для забезпечення потреб в електроенергії повинно бути вп’ятеро більше сонячних дахів та сонячних парків, ніж раніше.
Тоді фотогальваніка має забезпечувати чверть від загальної потреби німців в електроенергії.
У цій галузі нині досить багато нових замовлень на будівництво сонячних парків. Чим пояснюється такий бум?
За останні 10 років ціна на сонячні модулі впала приблизно до 10 відсотків від початкової ціни.
Це дозволяє нам у Німеччині виробляти електроенергію по 4-6 центів за кіловат-годину в таких відкритих системах,
що неможливо на жодній вугільній електростанції. Це неможливо і на атомних електростанціях.
Повернімося до найбільшого проєкту сонячного парку в Німеччині.
Ще десять років тому ця компанія, яка його будує, була одним з найбільших виробників атомної енергії.
Вона досі управляє кількома вугільними електростанціями, але з часом і їх закриють.
Нові види енергії мають заповнити цю прогалину, і для нас це вже стало основою у нашому портфоліо.
З 2012 року ми зросли у всіх сферах, у всіх нових та відновлюваних технологіях - таких як морський вітер, наземний вітер, а також фотогальваніка.
І ці види енергії становитимуть близько половини нашої потужності до 2025 року.
Сонячні модулі китайського виробництва доставляють на будівельний майданчик до пізнього вечора.
І так щодня, адже наприкінці року цей сонячний парк має вийти в мережу.